MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this lecture, we want to
talk about asymptotic freedom,
about confinement, and also
the running of the strength
of the strong force.
In the recitation,
we already talked
about vacuum polarization,
QED, and how it relates to QCD.
So here we're just going
to remind ourselves again
about what has been
discussed here.
So loop contributions
in QED, they
make the effective charge
a function of the momentum
transferred q.
So the coupling strength
increases with larger values
of q squared.
So a leading order, you have
to consider this diagram.
And you find that there
is a correction coming
from this kind of diagram.
m here is the mass
of the particle
involved in this correction.
But as you know, in
perturbation theory,
you have to consider
all possible diagrams.
And this is being done here.
So if you consider those
higher-order diagrams,
you can rewrite the
running of the QED coupling
as the coupling at q
squared of 0 divided by 1
minus this contribution here.
So there's a couple
of things to note.
So there's a 1
minus a factor here.
And then there's
also the definition
or the fixed point
of the coupling
that's being used
as 0 q squared.
But that's possible in QED.
But that will not
be possible in QCD,
because at momentum
transfer 0, the coupling
is going to be infinite.
So it's not well-defined and we
cannot use perturbation theory
at this value s either.
OK, good.
So in QCD, we have
not just one diagram,
like the one we just saw before.
But we also have to consider
the gluon self-coupling diagram.
So we have contributions
of this sort.
So I'll spare you
from the calculation.
But you find that the
gluon contribution
has an opposite effect.
So it's producing some sort of
anti-screening or camouflaging
of the color charge.
And so you find,
if you calculate
this in a very similar way
as you did just before,
we did just before for QED, we
find this kind of correction.
So here, we have
to define or fix
the strength of the coupling
at a specific scale.
And you see that you have
this contribution here.
There's a plus here,
but this factor here,
which is 11 times the
number of colors involved,
minus 2 times the number
of flavors involved.
Those numbers are 3 and
6, so hence 11 times
n is larger than 2 times f.
This becomes positive here.
And so therefore the
coupling decreases--
the coupling decreases
this q squared.
All right, since
it decreases with q
squared, at very,
very high q squared,
the coupling becomes 0.
And that's the origin
of asymptotic freedom.
In the limit of very
large q squared,
strongly charged particles,
color-charged particles
become free.
That's also the reason
why at very high energies
we can make calculations in
QCD using the Feynman calculus
or perturbation theory.
In the other direction, if
you go to very low q squared,
those methods and tools
are not possible anymore.
And quarks and gluons
are actually confined.
You cannot produce a non-color
thing that stays by themselves.
You cannot have a free
gluon or free quark.
So let's look at this
running a little bit more.
So we have this annoying alpha
s over function of q squared.
You can get rid of this actually
by redefining the parameter
here and using this lambda
parameter, or lambda QCD
as it's often called,
or lambda color
as it's called here under C.
When we do this, we can
rewrite the equations.
So we find that there
is no dependency anymore
of the scale involved.
And we don't have to
find this fixed point.
We still have the
dependency of 11n minus 2f.
And then this locked
dependency on q
squared over this
specific scale.
So the strength of the coupling
with this definition defined
for any value of q squared,
finding this lambda q,
this is kind of complicated
because if you go to very low q
square, calculations and
experiments cannot easily be
compared anymore.
So we find that lambda QCD is
in the order of 100 to 500 MeV.
OK, here are experimental
measurements, so alpha.
The strength of the
strong interaction
has been measured
in many experiments.
We can measure
this, for example,
in decays of tau leptons where
there's hadrons being produced,
and therefore you have
sensitivity to alpha s.
You can use found states deep in
elastic scattering experiment.
And PDF [?] fits can be used
in order to constrain alpha s.
We can use e-plus
e-minus physics
and look at the
distribution of jets.
We saw that the additional
radiation of a gluon
is sensitive to this vertex
of a quark radiating a gluon,
and therefore to
the strength of QCD.
You find that those
experiments are
all in reasonable agreement.
This line here indicates
now the average value
at a specific scale.
And typically when people
compare measurements,
they use the scale of the
Z boson mass, about 90 GeV,
in order to compare the values.
And you can see here,
the running of alpha
s, the running of the strong
coupling, a function of q,
and you see the behavior
of asymptotic freedom,
meaning that the
coupling becomes
small at very large value
of q, and very large--
small values of [INAUDIBLE].
All right, so that's it
for asymptotic freedom
and the running of alpha s.
We have a little bit more
of a discussion in QCD
before we enter
the next chapter.